[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi c'est arthur j'ai 23 ans et
je suis un être humain
chez moi m'a chambré à laitages au fond
du couloir c'est la porte de gauche ma
plante préférée c'est le philodendron et
mon animal préféré c'est la grenouille
dendrobates
et plutôt cool non
et chez moi ce que j'aime bien c'est mes
mollets en fait je les trouve harmonieux
et plutôt bien proportionné
et maintenant qu'on a un peu plus intime
on peut commencer
d'abord je suis super content on est
enthousiaste d'être avec vous ce soir
aujourd'hui pour partager un moment de
vie et nous poser ensemble quelques
questions voire même beaucoup de
questions
quand je me suis présenté au début de
notre rencontre j'en ai vu sourire et
c'est normal vous avez souri parce que
je suis sorti du canada parce que j'ai
pas dit ce que vous imaginez j'allais
dire
parce que dans tous les contextes et
toutes les situations quand on se
présente on suit un schéma qui est ultra
normes et social souvent on commence par
notre nom et prénom votre âge votre
métier après on part de nos passions ce
qui vous fait vibrer vraiment du tennis
la lecture du yoga que sais-je
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses ou ne met
en avant que des choses qui sont
socialement valorisé moi j'ai jamais
entendu personne me dire salut moi c'est
jean marie bourbier je me rends chez
tombe de pied et on reste plus que deux
points sont pas ils sont charmants
permis de conduire et même si c'est vrai
mais alors est-ce qu'en suivant cette
trame tout fait on répond vraiment la
question
qui sommes nous et bien pas vraiment
creuser et bien sûr aux habiles à rio
ouais j'ai prélevé deux espagnols lui
explique pourquoi c'est un scientifique
du langage il a étudié la présence la
présentation de soi comme aspect
relationnel et décision interactionnelle
il dit que tout projet identitaire
nécessite la validation d'autrui et
quand on se présente on revendique un
projet on ose exposer aux autres ce que
l'on est de plus on attend de l'audience
une validation et de la reconnaissance
de son côté l'audience composé d'une
somme de projet identitaire attend que
le nouvel individu sont en phase avec le
projet du groupe
vous l'avez compris quand on se présente
on joue un rôle aseptisé qui sera
d'emblée validé par l'audience
en conclusion nous ne sommes pas ce que
nous disons m
en revanche
sommes-nous ce que nous faisons c'est
une bonne question ça est-ce qu'on
remplit notre fonction à faire ce qu'on
fait
c'est ça la nature d'une chose c'est sa
fonction
mais d'un autre clé notre fonction note
nature par exemple la montre que j'ai
mon poignet elle a été inventée par
peter en lin en 1510 il a inventé la
montre parce qu'ils voulaient savoir
combien de temps il dormait de leurs
fonctions de la montre sa nature elle
est claire elle est définie mais la
nôtre
alors moi perso si je me posais la
question je me répondrait que c'est
d'apprendre des trucs cool d'en
rencontrer des gens intéressants de
voyages et de discuter
en fait c'est beau
mais c'est pas très convaincant
et c'est là qu'on a la chance cette fin
2021 et que des penseurs très doués
soient nés avant nous pour nous donner
quelques pistes et d'ailleurs cjp qui va
nous file un coup de main jp c'est bon
pour tout le monde jean paul sartre
ouais il paye pas de mine mais c'est un
gars ultra costaud et grâce à lui on va
avoir une réponse ou plutôt une non
réponse
il dit que l'existence humaine précède
l'essence qu'en fait la nature de
l'homme n'a aucune fonction clairs et
définis et que c'est ça qui nous rend
libres
l'homme est libre car il a la
potentialité et la liberté d'être et de
devenir tout ce qu'il souhaite être et
devenir
c'est plutôt cool et rassureront comme
mesure des choses non mais j'étais ils
vont encore plus loin il dit que
cherchait une fonction à son existence
c'est se renier notre seule raison
d'être est de ne pas être mais de
pouvoir tout devenir ma montre elle
n'est que montrer elle ne restera que m
mais l'humain n'est que rien
n' ont arrêté un malaise vous allez me
dire banque était sympa mais moi je
pense me définir parce que je suis ce
que je fais ce que je pense comment
toutes mes phrases part je suis je fais
je pense je ne suis rien je ne suis
qu'un devenir qui ne deviendra jamais
et oui mon gars
note nature semble bien obscur mais
qu'en est il de notre mesure
n'est ce pas plus simple de mesurer que
de définir finalement alors où commence
et où se termine notre propre corps on
est un tout petit corps de quelques
dizaines de kilos bloqué entre deux
infinis qui nous dépasse totalement
d'ailleurs est en mesure tout on utilise
le litre pour les volumes le maître pour
les distances le g pour les masses mais
où commence et où se termine notre
propre corps
et pour nous aider à répondre à cette
question je vous propose trois pistes
trois chemins et deux d'entre eux se
trouve ici
cette fresque c'est l'école d'athènes
elles étaient peintes par raphaël entre
1508 et 1512 pendant que peter se
raconte avec sa montre
et on peut voir les plus grands
philosophes de l'époque comme epicure
diogène platon et des mathématiciens il
ya pythagore et archimède au premier
plan ça vous intéresse et en fait on va
se concentrer sur les deux moustiques du
milieu à gauche platon à droite aristote
c'est un fight digne des plus grosses
bastons de l'aéroport d'orly
de son côté platon pense que la mesure
de l'homme est infinie
que son corps n'est qu'une entrave il
est même le tombeau de l'âme
de son côté arrêt faute pense au
contraire que l'homme n'est que son
corps qu'il n'est que sensations
aristote c'est l'empirisme c'est le
rationalisme aristote c'est ton pote qui
continue dit que tu as en galère avec ta
box n'a pas internet il te réponds tu
essaies de débrancher et rebrancher
alors que ton notre pote qui est plus
chez platon il battre et vous
aimez la vie elle dira 80 piges et quand
tu seras mort-aux-rats la fibre et tu
vas t'y fédou
quant à moi lors d'une séance même si on
a défini les limites de mon corps d'une
troisième manière
encore comme le vôtre elle est confinée
sans mauvais jeu de mots entre mon
centre et toutes les normes sociales
éducatives que j'ai reçu et donc mes
mouvements et les agissements sont en
constant rebond entre mon centre et
cette deuxième peau et grâce à elle je
n'insulte pas la boulangère quand elle
donne une tradition pas cuites alors que
je les préfère croustillantes ou je ne
font pas en larmes quand la machine
oublie la touillette dans mon café en
fait cette deuxième peau me sert de
socle et de repères pour ne pas me
perdre dans l'environnement sauce grâce
à elle mon corps est acceptée
alors je voulais choisir entre ces trois
chemins ces trois pistes à votre guise
je peux même vous dès le numéro de dr
garcia bon alors c'est moins sexy platon
aristote mais bon j'ai pas leur 0,6
et pour vous aider à choisir entre ces
trois chemins je vous propose de prendre
un petit peu de recul sur le monde dans
lequel nous sommes tous nés
un monde où avoir la tête loin des pieds
est d'être un grand homme
un monde où à l'école avoir un 18 sur 20
signifie être intelligent un monde où
faire du 90 des et pesait 40 kg et être
une belle femme
en réponse à quoi de ce monde
dans ce monde une ligne sur une carte
entre deux pays est un mur de briques
sur lequel on peut se cogner et se faire
mal et où 3000 migrants ont perdu la vie
en 2020
dans ce monde pour protéger ceux qu'on
aime il faut s'en éloigner et vivre
masquée
moi je le vis au monde
dans ce monde l'argent est devenu
l'unité de toutes choses de ce monde
l'argent est une nature est plus une
mesure
dans ce monde chaque bien un prix chaque
mètre carré est estimé chaque
accélération des dieux le petit pont
coûte 180 millions
il est la seconde
alors aujourd'hui je vous propose de
changer de mesures pour ne pas trahir
notre nature et prendre le temps
le temps n'est ce pas la seule chose que
nous avons tous en commun ici tout de
suite
ni l'homme ni l'argent ne peut être la
mesure de toute chose
filmer un homme qui marche sur un chemin
et accélérer crimes encore encore encore
et encore et l'homme disparaît
quelles preuves avant de de son
existence c'est le temps qui donne de la
légitimité à tous ceux qui existent
sans le temps nous n'existons pas et
nous ne devenons rien
alors
notre unique nature est notre unique
mesure se trouve ici entre nous
ni le g ni le litre milo m ni l'homme ni
l'argent ni le pouvoir ni la gloire ne
peut justifier notre existence mais le
temps oui
alors tant pis je veux trahi car à
toutes mes questions je ne répond ni nom
ni oui
de ma montre je m'affranchis
car c'est la liberté qui m'a séduit
je vous remercie car ensemble nous avons
appris aujourd'hui nous avons compris
que c'est le temps et seulement lui qui
construit merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]